the thing that causes the greatest
amount of suffering is craving an
attachment
so if you're so involved in sort of
doing this thing to help others
[Music]
and you do it so much that it harms
yourself then uh and and that you know
being able to say you know I helped a
tent like effective altruist I help 10
000 people today the ROI here is
incredible yet you know you've been up
for days at a time you're exhausted you
have no relationship with anybody that's
not a healthy thing and if you don't
make it to whatever that goal is then
you start all these self recriminations
saying you know I knew I could you know
it wasn't real I couldn't really do it I
tried but you know I wasn't good enough
and I wasn't worthy and I don't really
deserve this and I'm an imposter by
telling people that I'm trying to do
this and you beat yourself up well
that's only causing you suffering so if
you sit there and say you know my goal
is to let's say help ten thousand people
or whatever it is
and you sit there and you help eight
thousand you go you know I did an
incredible job was it exactly what I
want to know but I'm okay because at the
end of the day I did an incredible job
and you know even for some of the stuff
I do and do I have dreams and
aspirations about helping people
of course and a zillion times I've not
been able to do what I wanted and and uh
and I failed and I made mistakes and uh
um and it's
painful for myself but I'm still a
worthy person deserving of love right
one thing I want to talk he said
you've had like by any sort of
definitions of success like stupidly
large amounts of success
um a lot of
books I've read from people from people
who are very successful they often
lament that they didn't spend enough
time on their relationships when they
were sort of on the road to that success
I wonder if you can can speak to that at
all maybe in your life or if you were to
give advice for other people who are all
sort of aiming for Success this balance
between taking care of your personal
relationships alongside the
climbing the mountain
so let me give some information that
correlates or relates to our
conversation on compassion
I'm sure you're aware of the blue zones
in the world the butt nurse work I think
it is Butner
um
so these are places in the world uh I'm
sure many of your listeners have heard
of this where you know people live
routinely over a century
and uh
why is that
and this is
substantiated by a number of studies
so one part of it which people will
claim is these are people who eat a
Mediterranean diet
uh who exercise who are at their ideal
body weight who don't drink alcohol and
there's no question that is a
significant contributor but by far far
multitudes more important is depth of
relationships and human connection that
is the secret sauce all the other stuff
can be a benefit
uh but the secret sauce of of actually
longevity is human relationships and
connecting with others and and what does
that involve it involves having
generosity
uh um
be non-judgmental
being accepting
and of course those are the fundamentals
of how to develop relationships and
you're right there are some people are
so goal or in it and in fact they have
no problem stepping on other people
to get what they want because they want
some external validation
and probably there's some degree of in
security that they want to hold that
over other people uh but you know that's
not going to create happiness or
longevity and I'm sure you know uh a
number of let's and I hate to beat up
the hedge fund business
but uh uh
you know they're people who are you know
in that uh business of making money for
the sole purpose of making money at
whatever cost uh and uh uh you know they
work ridiculously hard uh and is it
great to live in a big Penthouse and
drive sports cars and hang out with
supermodels
I suppose I'm being I've been in that
position on some level and frankly I at
the end of the day my whole life I felt
was completely empty I had tons of
external people going man dude you live
in this incredible life you know you've
got this Penthouse and you know you've
got this Ferrari and you're dating
someone so man you should be so happy
and I I was never happy in that
situation I was miserable actually and
it and to the point where I couldn't
understand because I did all of this
stuff
and I was miserable when all my friends
said would say God if I was in your
position I would be so happy right now
but again if it's all about the money or
all about the you know killing yourself
to get some external validation you're
you're going to be unhappy uh at least
you know that's been my personal
experience in my uh observation hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye